Kailangan nating lahat ng kakayahang makipag-communicate ng pribadong impormasyon nang walang takot na may nakarinig. Ngunit ang pagdidisenyo ng isang
foolproof na sistema para dito ay hindi madali. Sa episode na ito ng Qiskit in the Classroom, pag-uusapan natin kung paano
ang tinatawag na quantum key distribution ay
makakatulong. Maligayang pagbabalik sa Qiskit in the Classroom. Sa seryeng ito, tatakpan natin ang mga paksa na maaari mong maranasan sa isang quantum
computing na kaugnay na kurso sa unibersidad. Ang bawat video ay may kasamang interactive na module na naka-link sa paglalarawan kaya
siguraduhing tingnan iyon. Ngayon, maglalakbay tayo sa larangan ng quantum cryptography. Ang cryptography ay ang pag-aaral
ng mga teknik para sa secure na komunikasyon. Ito ay napakahalagang bahagi ng maraming aspeto ng ating buhay. Sa tuwing gumagamit ka ng
password upang mag-log in sa isang website, magpadala ng digital na bayad, o kapag nagpapadala ang mga pamahalaan ng military intel, lahat ito ay ginagawa
sa pamamagitan ng ilang cryptographic protocol upang hindi matuto ang isang nakikinig ng ating mga lihim. Ngunit may tensyon dito. Paano
natin tiyakin na ang taong nais nating kausapin ay makakaUnawa ng ating mensahe ngunit hindi ang sinuman pa?
Kasaysayan, nakalikha ang mga cryptographer ng maraming iba't ibang protocol upang subukang gawing immune ang kanilang mga mensahe
mula sa mga nakikinig hangga't maaari. Minsan ang dalawang partido na nais na makipag-communicate nang ligtas ay sumasang-ayon sa ilang
code nang maaga na umaasa na napaka-kumplikado para sa isang nakikinig na hindi siya makakabasag nito. Ngunit gaya ng
ipinakita sa atin ng mga tao tulad ni Alan Turing at iba pang wartime code breaker, kahit ang pinakamagkakumplikadong code ay maaaring
masira. Nais sana nating magpadala ng mga mensahe na naka-encrypt sa paraan na walang pattern
at walang paraan na maunawaan ng isang nakikinig nang hindi nagtataglay ng isang lihim na random na susi na alam lamang ng nagpadala at ng
tatanggap. Ngunit pagkatapos ay magbubukas tayo sa isang bagong kahinaan. Paano natin maipadala ang susing ito at matiyak na
walang nakaka-intercept nito? Noong 1984, si Charles Bennett at Jill Brassard ay nakalikha ng
paraan upang ligtas na maipadala ang isang susi gamit ang mga quantum bit na tinatawag na ngayon na BB84. Ang pangunahing katangian ng mga quantum
bit o qubit na nagpapahintulot sa protocol na ito ay ang pagsunod nila sa uncertainty principle. Hindi mo maaaring sukatin
ang isang quantum system nang hindi ito nagagambala. Ngayon, magsisimula tayo sa isang halimbawa ng simpleng cryptographic code. Pagkatapos ay
ipapakita ko sa iyo kung paano ang quantum key distribution at ang uncertainty principle ay makakapagpahintulot sa atin na gumamit ng halos hindi masisirang
encryption. Ilalakad kita sa BB84 protocol nang detalyado at sa wakas ay patakbuhin natin ito sa isang tunay na quantum
computer. Una, magsimula tayo sa isang laro na maaaring napanood mo na bago na tinatawag na cryptogram.
Bibigyan ka ng isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng tila random na mga titik ngunit sa paggamit ng iyong kaalaman sa mga pattern sa wikang Ingles
maaari kang mag-substitute ng isang titik para sa isa pa upang maunawaan ang mensahe. Narito ang isang halimbawa. Ito ay isang
lihim na mensahe na may simpleng substitution cipher. Kaya lahat ng R ay kumakatawan sa isang titik ang M ay kumakatawan
sa isa pa at iba pa. Kung nais mong subukan ang paglutas nito sa iyong sarili, i-pause ang video ngayon.
Pala ang mensaheng ito ay naka-encrypt gamit ang isang napaka-simpleng cipher na tinatawag na Caesar cipher kung saan ang
alpabeto ay inililipat lamang ng isang tiyak na bilang sa kasong ito 9. Kaya ang A ay nagiging J ang B
ay nagiging K ang C ay nagiging L at iba pa. Habang mas mahaba ang mensahe mas madali itong
makita ang pattern. Kaya sa mensahe na kasinghaba ng ibinibigay sa atin ang Caesar cipher o anumang ibang cipher na
nagpapalit lamang ng isang titik sa alpabeto para sa isa pa ay medyo simple ang pagsira. Isang mas secure na paraan upang i-encode ang isang lihim
na mensahe ay gamit ang tinatawag na one-time pad. Sa isang one-time pad maaari kang magkaroon ng iba't ibang shift para sa bawat titik sa
mensahe. Kailangan mo lamang sabihin sa iyong kaibigan kung ano ang shift sa bawat isa upang maa-decode nila ang mensahe.
Ang listahan ng mga shift na ito ay tinatawag na susi o ang pad. Ito ay tinatawag na one-time pad dahil ginagamit ito nang isang beses pagkatapos ay itinapon.
Kung ginagamit ito nang higit sa iyon, lilitaw ang mga pattern na maaaring gawing masisira ang encryption. Sa one-time
pad na encryption ang parehong naka-encrypt na mensahe at ang susi nang hiwalay ay isang random na string ng nonsense lamang. Ngunit
kapag pinagsama mo ang mga ito makikita mo ang isang lihim na mensahe na lumalabas mula sa ingay.
Gumawa tayo ng maikling halimbawa. Sabihin nating nagawa na akong magpadala sa aking kaibigan ng one time pad na ito na karaniwang isinusulat sa
binary. At pagkatapos ay nais kong ipadala ang mensaheng I love quantum. Pagkatapos ay iko-encode ko ang mensahe
gamit ang one-time pad ganito. Una kino-convert natin ang mga titik sa ating mensahe sa binary. Ang bawat titik A hanggang Z ay
katumbas ng mga bilang 1 hanggang 26 na isinusulat sa binary. Kaya ang A ay magiging 0 0
0 1 ang B ay 0 0 1
0 ang C ay 0 0 1 1 at iba
pa. At pagkatapos ang isang espasyo ay magiging lahat ng mga zero.
Pagkatapos ito ang magiging mensahe. Ino-encode natin ang mensahe sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng XOR sa pagitan ng bawat bit sa mensahe at
ang katumbas na bit nito sa one-time pad. Kung hindi mo pa nakita ang XOR dati,
ito ay tumutukoy sa exclusive or. Ang XOR sa pagitan ng dalawang bit ay magiging isa kung isa lamang
sa mga bit ang isa at zero kung pareho silang zero o pareho silang isa. Kaya ang unang hanay ng limang bit sa naka-encode
na mensahe ay nagiging 1 0
0 1 1. Iiiwan ko ang natitirang mga XOR para sa iyo na gawin sa iyong sarili. Ngunit ang punto ay
ang mensaheng ito ay isang random na string na lamang ng mga zero at isa na walang pattern. Ito ay ganap na hindi mabasa ng sinumang
walang one-time pad na ginamit natin upang i-encrypt ang mensahe. Kaya ano ang natutunan natin hanggang ngayon? Ang ilang encryption
scheme ay mas maganda kaysa sa iba at ang ilan ay maaaring ma-infer ng isang matalinong tao na naghahanap ng mga pattern sa naka-encrypt
na mensahe. Ngunit ang isang tunay na random na susi na nagpapalit ng bawat titik sa isang lihim na mensahe ng iba't ibang random na halaga ay hindi maaaring
ma-infer dahil walang mga pattern sa mensahe. Ang tanging kahinaan sa isang scheme tulad nito ay ang pagtitiyak
na ang susing ginamit upang i-encrypt ang mensahe ay hindi mapupunta sa maling kamay. Narito ang tungkulin ng quantum key
distribution. Sa paggamit ng mga qubit, nakalikha si Bennett at Brassard ng paraan para sa dalawang partido na sumang-ayon sa isang susi at
maging medyo tiwala na ang isang third party ay hindi lihim na nakikinig. Ang BB84 protocol na ito ay medyo kumplikado ngunit
daraan tayo rito hakbang sa hakbang. Para sa paliwanag na ito, ibabalik natin ang ating mga lumang kaibigan si Alice at
Bob. Ang protocol ay nagsisimula sa paghahanda ni Alice ng isang hanay ng mga qubit na ipapadala kay Bob. Ang mga qubit na ito ay naglalaman ng
impormasyon na magiging kanilang shared one-time pad o susi. Una ay bumubuo si Alice ng dalawang random na pagkakasunod-sunod ng
parehong haba. Ang isa ay isang random na pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga zero at isa at ang isa pa ay isang random na pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga x at z na kumakatawan sa
basis kung saan ihahanda niya ang kanyang mga qubit. Pagkatapos ay ihahanda niya ang bawat qubit sa isang quantum state ayon sa
kombinasyon ng basis at bit value na ipinapakita sa chart na ito. Kaya kung ang bit ay zero at ang basis ay z, ihahanda niya
ang qubit sa zero state. o kung ang bit ay isa at ang basis ay X, ihahanda niya ito sa minus state. Kung
hindi ka sigurado kung ano ang mga basis at quantum state na ito okay lang iyon. Ang pangunahing punto na kailangan mong malaman ay ang
mga sukat sa bawat basis ay laging may dalawang posibleng resulta lamang. 0 o isa para sa Z basis at plus o minus para sa X
basis. Kung susukat ka ng estado zero sa Z basis lagi kang makakakuha ng zero.
Ngunit kung susukat ka ng parehong estado sa x basis makakakuha ka ng random na resulta alinman sa plus o minus bawat isa ay may 50%
tsansa. Kaya maaaring maghanda si Alice ng isang string ng mga qubit ganito kung saan narito ang random na string ng
mga zero at isa at narito ang random na string ng mga x at z. Kaya ang unang elemento sa bawat isa sa kanyang
dalawang pagkakasunod-sunod ay 0 at x. Ibig sabihin ihahanda niya ang unang qubit sa plus state at iba
pa. Kapag nailaan niya na ang lahat ng kanyang qubit state, magpapadala si Alice kay Bob ng mga qubit na ito at si Bob ay random na pipili sa pagitan ng X
at Z bilang basis kung saan susukatin ang bawat isa. Kaya nagdaragdag na tayo ng ilang row sa
chart upang katawanin ang mga pagpili at sukat ni Bob. Kaya narito ang mga
sukat at pagpili ng basis ni Bob. At narito ang kanyang mga resulta ng pagsukat ng mga qubit na ipinadala ni Alice sa kanya. Sa wakas si Bob
ay maaaring mag-convert ng bawat sukat sa isang bit gamit ang parehong talahanayan na ginamit ni Alice upang ihanda ang kanyang mga qubit. Kapag sinukat niya ang
zero o plus state itinatakda niya ang bit value na zero. At kung sinukat niya ang isa o minus state naglalagay siya ng
isa. Kaya ang huling bit string ni Bob ay ang huling row na ito.
Pansinin na kapag ang mga basis ng hakbang ng paghahanda ni Alice at hakbang ng pagsukat ni Bob ay magkapareho ang kanilang mga bit ay magkatugma rin
pati na rin. Ngunit kung pinili ni Alice na maghanda ng Z at sumukat si Bob sa X o vice versa
ang mga katumbas na bit ni Alice at Bob ay hindi kinakailangang magkapareho. Kaya isang paraan na parehong maaari silang sumang-ayon sa isang bit string
para sa kanilang one-time pad ay ang pagtawag sa isa't isa at pagsasabi sa isa't isa kung anong mga basis ang ginamit nila para sa bawat qubit.
Kapag magkapareho ang mga basis pinapanatili nila ang bit at kapag hindi itinatapon nila ito.
Kaya sa kasong ito si Alice at Bob ay parehong sasang-ayon sa isang bit string na 0 0 1 0
0. Paano pinoprotektahan ng scheme na ito laban sa hindi napansin na mga nakikinig? Tingnan natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag ang naturang nakikinig na
nagngangalang Eve ay nakaka-intercept ng mga qubit na ipinapadala ni Alice kay Bob. Hindi niya alam kung anong estado ang mga qubit na ito o kung paano
nila inihanda ni Alice ang mga ito. Kaya salamat sa uncertainty principle at sa isang bagay na tinatawag na no cloning theorem hindi siya maaaring
gumawa lamang ng isang magkaparehong kopya ng mga qubit upang ipasa kay Bob. Kung magagawa niya iyon maaari siyang
maniktik nang hindi natuklasan. Sa halip, huhulaan niya ang isang basis kung saan susukatin ang bawat qubit, susukatin ang mga ito at pagkatapos ay
maghahanda ng bagong hanay ng mga peke na qubit upang ipadala kay Bob. Mayroong iba pang mas tuso na paraan na maaaring subukan ni Eve na
malaman ang tungkol sa mga qubit ngunit wala sa mga ito ang nakakaalis sa uncertainty principle.
Kaya ipapalagay natin lamang ang simpleng paraan na ito ng pakikinig ni Eve. Narito ang isang chart na naglalarawan
ng paghahanda ni Alice, pakikinig ni Eve at huling sukat ni Bob. Kaya ngayon kapag
kausap ni Alice at Bob ang isa't isa sa telepono upang ikumpara ang kanilang mga basis, magpapasya silang panatilihin ang mga bit na ito para sa kanilang susi ngunit ang
mga bit ay hindi magkatugma. Ito ay dahil si Bob ay sumusukat ng mga qubit na inihanda ni Eve hindi ang orihinal na mga qubit na mayroon si Alice.
Kung ikukumpara nila ang isang subset ng mga bit sa kanilang mga bit string sa isa't isa makikita nila na ang ilan ay hindi magkatugma at
maaalagang may nakikinig. Kaya dahil natuklasan si Eve itatapon ni Alice at Bob ang kanilang mga
bit string at sisimulan muli ang protocol mula sa simula. Ngunit kung hindi nakikinig si Eve at ang subset ng mga
bit na ikinkumpara ni Alice at Bob ay magkatugma maaari na silang sumulong at gamitin ang natitirang mga bit na hindi nila
ikinkumpara bilang kanilang shared key. Kapag mayroon na si Alice at Bob ng isang shared key maaari nang magpadala si Alice ng mga naka-encrypt na mensahe kay Bob at
si Bob lamang ang makaaka-decrypt ng mga ito gamit ang susi. Ngayon na dumaan tayo sa protocol, subukan natin ito sa isang
quantum computer. Mayroong ilang bagay na dapat isaalang-alang para sa eksperimentong ito. Una,
ang BB84 ay talagang kapaki-pakinabang lamang kung si Alice at Bob ay malayo sa isa't isa. Para sa eksperimentong gagawin natin si Alice
at Bob ay nasa parehong quantum chip. Kaya ang eksperimentong ito ay hindi magiging kapaki-pakinabang para sa pagpapalitan ng pribadong impormasyon ngunit ito ay
isang magandang conceptual na demonstrasyon ng BB84.
Pangalawa, ang mga tunay na quantum computer ay may ingay. Kaya kahit na ang basis ng paghahanda ni Alice ay tumutugma sa basis ng pagsukat ni Bob
at walang nakikinig, mayroon pa rin na maliit na tsansa na susukat sila ng iba't ibang bit dahil sa mga error sa
quantum computer. Kapag ikukumpara nila ang kanilang mga bit string upang suriin ang mga nakikinig kailangan nilang magkaroon ng ilang tolerance para sa mga error bago sila
magsimpulan na may nakikinig na tiyak na nakikialam sa kanila at itatapon nila ang buong susi. Ngayon na may mga
caveat na iyon, magsimula tayo sa isang eksperimento na walang nakikinig. Una random na
bumubuo tayo ng tatlong iba't ibang bit string na bawat isa ay may 20 bit. Ang una ay ang paunang bit
string ni Alice. Ang pangalawa ay isang listahan ng mga basis kung saan ihahanda ni Alice ang kanyang mga qubit.
Dito pinili natin ang zero upang katawanin ang Z basis at isa upang katawanin ang X basis. Ang huling listahan ay ang mga basis kung saan
susukatin ni Bob ang bawat qubit. Batay sa tatlong listahan na iyon maaari tayong gumawa ng circuit diagram na may mga tagubilin para sa
paghahanda ni Alice at mga sukat ni Bob. Lahat ng qubit ay nagsisimula sa zero state. Kaya upang ihanda ang kanyang mga qubit sa
Z basis si Alice ay alinman ay walang ginagawa para sa zero state o nag-apply ng not o X gate na ipinapakita bilang mga asul na kahon na may label na X
para sa one state. Upang maghanda sa X basis nag-apply siya ng alinman sa Hadamard gate na nagdadala ng zero sa plus state
o isang not gate na sinusundan ng isang Hadamard upang maghanda ng minus state. Pagkatapos ipinapadala niya ang mga qubit kay Bob. Ang susunod na hanay ng mga kahon
sa circuit ay kumakatawan sa mga sukat ni Bob. Upang sumukat sa Z basis hindi na siya kailangang mag-apply ng anumang dagdag na gate.
Susukat lamang siya na ipinapakita ng mga gray na kahon na ito. Upang sumukat sa X basis una ay nag-apply siya ng Hadamard at
pagkatapos ay sumukat siya. Patatabuhin natin ang circuit na ito gamit ang Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. At ang output ay ang bit
string ng mga sukat ni Bob. Pagkatapos maaari tayong ikumpara ang mga bit string ni Bob sa paunang bit string ni Alice na itinatapon ang mga bit
kung saan hindi magkatugma ang kanilang mga basis. At makikita natin na pareho silang nakakakuha ng parehong susi.
Tandaan na ito ay tunay na hardware kaya paminsan-minsan ay maaaring magkaroon ng bit na dapat magkatugma ngunit hindi. Sa kasong ito lahat ng
bit ay magkatugma ngunit kung patatabuhin mo ito muli sa iyong sarili maaari kang makakuha ng error ngunit hangga't ang fidelity ay malapit sa isa
si Alice at Bob ay maaaring maging medyo tiwala na walang nakikinig. Ngayon tingnan natin kung ano ang mangyayari kung nakikinig si Eve sa
mga qubit. Ngayon mayroon tayong dalawang circuit. Ang una ay nagpapakita ng paghahanda ni Alice at pakikinig at
pagsukat ni Eve. Ang susunod ay nagpapakita ng paghahanda ni Eve ng mga peke na qubit at sukat ni Bob. Maaari
nating patatabuhin ang mga circuit na ito tulad ng dati at pagkatapos ay tingnan kung ano ang makukuha ni Alice at Bob kapag ikukumpara nila ang kanilang mga bit
string. Sa pagkakataong ito nakakakuha sila ng fidelity na 6 repeating. Ito ay malayo mas mababa kaysa sa
maaaring maipaliwanag ng ingay sa quantum computer. Kaya nagsisimpulan sila na naniktik si Eve. Ang quantum computing ay
kilala at madalas na pinalaki ang loob para sa potensyal nitong malutas ng mga mahirap na problema. Ngunit ang quantum communication at cryptography
ay madalas na mas kaunting pansin kahit na ang potensyal na maaaring ialay ng quantum sa mga larangang ito ay pantay-pantay na
mahalaga at kapana-panabik. Ngayon tinalakay natin ang pinaka-maagang natuklasang protocol para sa quantum key distribution na
halos immune sa hindi natatuklaang pakikinig. Kung nais mong subukan ang pagpapadala ng isang hindi masisirang code gamit ang
isang quantum certified na susi pumunta sa module na naka-link sa paglalarawan.
Salamat sa panood at makikita kita sa susunod.